au bourget dans la ceinture rouge qui
fut autrefois le fief du parti
communiste cet immeuble anonyme aux
fenêtres fermées sur les deux derniers
étages où est accroché un panneau à
l'humour involontaire
cet immeuble est encore aujourd'hui le
siège de la cellule locale du parti
communiste
cette cellule fut en 1962 et pendant
quelques mois un adhérent aujourd'hui
célèbre bernard tapie qui avait alors 19
ans cette information est révélée par un
journaliste du figaro michel farkas par
ailleurs membre du rpr il est publié
dans la lettre local de la section rpr
du 7e arrondissement de paris je peux
fournir la preuve de ce que j'avance
c'est une photographie de sa carte
d'adhérent
la voilà vous savez ce document une
histoire bernard tapie temps week-end
avec quelques amis il évoqué des
souvenirs il a sorti quelques photos et
cette carte faire des ronds c'est un
seuil est très bon ami qui est retourné
la maison alors que tout le monde était
dans le jardin il l'a photographiée en
disant qu'un jour ça pouvait servir
effectivement quelques années plus tard
il l'a revendue et c'est en fait
l'acheteur qui est venu me proposer ce
document et qui me l'a donné j'ai pas
l'impression d'être manipulé en
définitive moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
la vérité je suis militant rpr je
combats les socialistes et bernard tapie
fait partie du gouvernement socialiste
puis je suis journaliste et j'ai enquêté
sur le terrain j'ai même pu retrouver un
camarade de bernard henry marais je me
souviens de bernard tapie n'ont pas
souvenir fulgurant mais je me souviens
que parmi ces centaines et ces milliers
de gens du parti communiste des
jeunesses communistes que j'ai
rencontrés au cours de 16 ans et demi le
militantisme en seine-saint-denis il y
avait un garçon qui s'appelait bernard
tapie il avait le sens des affaires
il faudra un rayon de cellules il y
avait des colleurs d'affichés militants
à travailler la nuit ils disaient mais
c'est colored affiche moyennant finances
au profit de la cellule pourrait bien
travaillé pour le cinéma d'en face qui
avait été acceptée et qui s'appelait
l'aviatic soit pour un casse un
d'électroménager je suis si j'ai pas
mais moi on avait évidemment refusé
cette idée qui nous paraissaient folle à
l'époque j'ai quitté les jeux de ce que
bullish une raison toute simple il n'a
pas envie d'être commandé le parti
communiste est à l'ordre un peu comme un
ordre religieux
on ne les tâches à accomplir dans les
délais précis c'est bien à retaper par
miss haïti la seule chose bien qu'il ait
fait de sa vie et je le vois dans la
force d'âme ils tous sur tapis et écrit
il a été communiste ce qu'il a cru au
peuple il a cru à une certaine
générosité
malheureusement ça n'a pas duré
longtemps il a quitté le parti et il a
commencé sa grande aventure d'escrocs
français